president bush it is my honor to be on
stage
thank you president
they are as residents today
governor tom wolf
superintendent of clark
it is truly an honor to be with all of
you at this field of honor
we are joined today of course by the
family and friends of the 40 passengers
and crew members
and we stand today
with all those
who lost someone
on september 11 2001.
these last 20 years
every time tucked in your children
or dropped them off at college
you have felt every day
every week
and every year
that has passed these 20 years
so please know your nation sees you
and we stand with you
and we support you
we are gathered today
on halloween
at this place
that has been sanctified
by sacrifice
to honor the heroism
that the 40 passengers and the crew
members
showed in the face
of
i remember when i first learned about
what happened on that faithful fight
what happened
on flight 93
told us then and it still tells us so
much
about the courage
of those on board who gave everything
they possibly could
about the resolve of the first
responders
who risked everything
and about the resilience of the american
people
on this 20th anniversary
on this some day of remembrance
we must challenge ourselves yes
to look back
to remember
for the sake of our children
for the sake of their children
and
for that reason
we must also look forward
we must also look
toward the future
because in the end i do believe that is
on the days that followed september 11
2001
we were all reminded
that unity is possible in america
we were reminded also
that unity
is an imperative
in america
it is essential
to our shared prosperity
to our national security
and to our standing in the world
and by unity i don't mean uniformity
we had differences of opinion in 2001
as we do in 2021
and i believe
that in america
our diversity
is our strength
at the same time
we saw after 9 11
how fear can be used
to sow division in our nation
as seeking muslim americans were
targeted because of how they looked or
how they worshipped
but we also saw
what happens
when so many americans
in the spirit of our nation
stand in solidarity
with all people and their fellow
and looking back
we remember
the vast majority of americans
to help communities
recover
to defend our nation
and to keep us safe
in a time of outright terror
we turned toward
each other
in the face of a stranger
we saw a neighbor and a friend
that time reminded us
the significance and the strength
of our unity as americans
and that it
is so
moments from now
we will leave this hallowed place
still carrying with us
the pain
of this loss
tremendous loss
and still
the future will continue to unfold
we will face new challenges
challenges that we could not have seen
20 years ago
we will see
opportunities
that were at one time unimaginable
and we know
that what lies ahead
is not certain it is never served
it
if we do the hard work
of working together as americans
if we remain
united in purpose
we will be prepared
for whatever comes next
the 40
passengers and crewmembers
of flight 93
as we all know they didn't they didn't
know each other most of them didn't know
each other
they were different people
from different places
they were on that particular flight for
different reasons
but they did not focus
on what
in a matter of minutes
in the most dire
circumstances
the 40
responded as one
they fought for their own lives
and to save the lives of countless
others at our nation's capital
after today it is my hope and prayer
that we continue
to honor their courage
their conviction
with our own
that we honor their unity
by strengthening
our common bonds
by strengthening
our global partnerships
and by always living out
our highest ideals
this work will not be easy it never has
been
and it will take
all of us
believing
in who we are
as a nation
and it will take all of us
going forth
to work together
thank you all may god bless you and may
god bless america